depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
sans précédent la france entière montre
son soutien à ces médecins ces aides
soignants ou encore ces infirmiers qui
sont mobilisées jour et nuit face à
cette crise est pourtant une profession
a l'impression d'être totalement oublié
alors qu'elle est en première ligne
il s'agit des ambulanciers maillon
essentiel de la chaîne des soins depuis
l'apparition du virus ils sont
constamment sollicités pour l'instant
c'est juste une suspicion c'est un
fondement que nous pouvons dire en plus
c'est pas vrai en corse et les médecins
qui décident
nous on fait que les transports
sanitaires d'un point a à un point b
et après on se protège nous mêmes on
protège les patients et emmené aux
urgences un petit peu comme tout le
monde mais si on ne le fait pas personne
qui veulent faire les protocoles sont
particulièrement lourd une fois le
patient déposé aux urgences l'ambulance
et tout le matériel qui s'y trouvent
sont entièrement désinfecté
une procédure qui prend en moyenne 45
minutes
alors on vient de faire un patient
coville suspicion qu'ovide donc on a
forcément une désinfection complète du
véhicule avec un produit bien
particulier donc pour éviter pour les
autres patients qu'on fait là aussi bien
des radiothérapies ce genre de choses
pour éviter qu'ils le puissent
l'attraper pour nous aussi mais surtout
pour eux pour le patient on met un
masque
après pour la désinfecte malheureusement
vu qu'on n'a pas énormément de masques
non plus on essaye de réduire au maximum
quand on nous dit que non vous êtes des
transporteurs et donc des ambulanciers
alors vous voyez réellement le travail
qu'ils ont effectué dans la journée
c'est pas que du transport c'est
vraiment l'assistance à la personne
les ambulanciers ne font pas partie des
professions prioritaires pour accéder
aux stocks de masques délivrés par les
pharmacies pourtant en ligne de front
ils craignent de ne plus être en mesure
de respecter les règles d'hygiène
et de sécurité imposées par la lutte
contre le coronavirus une situation qui
est devenue intenable pour ses gérants
d'une entreprise d'ambulances on y va
avec la peur au ventre parce qu'on n'a
pas de matériel on fait avec les moyens
du bord on y va quasiment du matériel
pyrénées je vous cache pas que j'ai fait
des fonds de tiroirs j'ai récupéré tout
ce que je pouvais récupérer
il quitte à récupérer des masques
périmés on a des personnes qui l'ont
jeté des collègues on jette l éponge
nous ont présenté notre démission qui
arrive sur vous on n'en peut plus on
arrête et on les comprend
on peut même pas les incriminer passé si
cruel à dire mais voilà on est vraiment
des oubliés de la république la maladie
on doit on doit être ensemble et faire
face ensemble dans un second temps on
verra on envisagera de de porter plainte
ou de déporter les âges des accents
justice parce qu'effectivement nous
envoie au casse pipe avec un du tout on
nous demande de porter les armes sans
munitions en attendant une réponse
rapide des autorités sanitaires à les
ambulanciers s'organise et c'est avant
tout le système d qui prévaut